let's do an example of using Newton's
second law and problem solving in this
example we'll figure out why riding in
an elevator can give you a weird
sensation of weightlessness or extra
weight depending on which way you're
accelerating so let's say there's a
person standing on a scale in the
elevator that's accelerating upwards
with some acceleration a so we want to
know what the scale reads first we need
to really understand what the scale
measures the number that it gives you is
related to the normal force that you are
exerting on the scale so this is a
Newton's third law pair force to the
normal force that the scale exerts on
you so if we can figure out the normal
force on the person from the scale we'll
know what the scale should read now
let's set up our coordinate system I'm
going to assign the upward direction to
be positive Y and since the only forces
in this problem are acting vertically I
don't need to define another direction
I'll pick the system to be the person
now I'll think about what we know and
what we don't since that person is
standing in the elevator not jumping not
moving otherwise they must be
accelerating upwards with acceleration a
the acceleration of the elevator I also
know the mass of the person so now I
have one side of Newton's second law now
I need to think about what vertical
forces are acting on the person first
there's the gravitational force pulling
the person down this gravitational force
does not depend on the acceleration of
the elevator because the gravitational
interaction is just between the person
and the earth so the force is minus mg
finally I have the normal force that's
holding the person up this is the normal
force from the interaction between the
person and the scale and so this is the
unknown quantity that I'd like to know
let's look at Newton's second law on the
Left I have FN the normal force that I'm
interested in minus mg the gravitational
pull from the earth
and on the right I have M the person's
mass times a the acceleration of the
elevator and therefore the person notice
that when the elevator is accelerating
the normal force and the gravitational
force do not have the same magnitude
that is they don't cancel out so now I
can solve for FN and I can find that
it's just M times the quantity a plus G
have you ever noticed that at the bottom
of an elevator ride when you're
accelerating upward you feel heavier and
at the top when you're decelerating you
often feel lighter you can see that if I
change a to minus a in this example that
I'll get the normal force is equal to M
times G minus a and this explains that
feeling of lightness it's always good to
check that your answers match physical
intuition and I encourage you to go and
play with elevators and other physical
phenomena around you while you're going
through this course to see if your
answers make physical sense